das papier soll max und heute gibt es
eine runde community clash zusammen mit
dem lieben rot etwas geht ein stück
beschreiben oder laut ich kann auch
leidig rein aber und das hier ist die
neue karte freunde ausgelegt für zehn
milliarden tausend spieler
wir werden das ganze jetzt gleich
ausprobieren dies übrigens von pixel
bieten sehr nice und natürlich sagen
stehen wir als ein und dann sehen wir
uns gleich in der runde wieder
du kennst das spielprinzip oder soll ich
noch mal klar na klar doch mal ganz
schnell ist also es gibt uns beide als
könige dann gibt es innerhalb unserer
teams unterschiedliche klassen nämlich
den tank bogenschützen und
schwertkämpfer und es geht darum
wirklich viele kids zu machen wenn zum
beispiel ein care-team dein team
ausgelöscht hat dann gewinnen wir und es
geht ins king duell also nur noch wir
beide sind auf der karte und für jeden
von meinen spielern dennoch lebt kriege
ich einen shop punkt und dann kann ich
alle ausrüsten und mir entfiel zeug
koppen für den shop mit dem ich dich
dann alle mit dem inhalt vorteile
absolut bestes waren am ende
okay leute wir sind auf der karte 37
gegen 7 30 kämpfen wir
aber felix spielt das erste mal ich
spiele zum ersten mal seit einer langen
zeit wir wahrscheinlich alle wisst wo
wir spielen auf dieser wunderschönen
neuen karte dies auf jeden fall echt
doof aber die distanzen sind ja riesig
aber es scheint diese weise du hast wäre
ich habe ihm nicht bekommen h55 und
alter wir sind martin okay des tracking
ok das tracking funktioniert perfekt ja
gut damit ist ja garantiert dass nicht
gekämpft werden kann
das ist schon mal sehr nice damit ist
schon echt riesig die map ja und es hat
jeder nur einen ein herziger wieviel
lang mal laufen muss ja gut leute wir
müssen wir nehmen es relativ relativ
spät aus für unter einer woche als kommt
er heute noch und wird 3000 jahre lang
nicht mehr community patch aufnahmen
beim nächsten mal wenn es auf dieser
karte gespielt wird werden wir
hoffentlich ein paar mehr leute seien
aber jetzt kommt mir ist das erst mal
läuft erstmal zehn minuten ich bin immer
noch nicht da ich weiß gar nicht wo das
ende ist alte wie groß ist die karte ich
hoffe dass wir nicht beim king gehört
auch die ganze distanz müssen aber ich
bin ganz schnell kriegt das heißt wir
kriegen ground krankhafter partie
ich werde mich nicht verziehen 1 die fed
geht los und zurückziehen zurückziehen
zurückziehen ich ziehe mich dafür zurück
weil ich kein bock auf den ganzen weg zu
laufen
okay ich hab kein bock darunter zwei ins
wasser ich gehe auch mal distanz ich
gehe auf distanz und einfach ein paar
reifen perfekt läuft und trifft halt
einfach immer junge wird es richtig geil
ist verteilen es kommen immer noch leute
nach ja komplett instand vermieten sind
jetzt zwei leute gestorben seien
schlecht oder deine community ist
einfach schlecht
walter ich mir über den ganzen region
okay ich hab einen trick neben mir wert
kennen
ok leichten bogen hier im wasser team
zurückkommt muss mich nach ok 32 26
felix motivierten leuten fußvolk
motiviert jetzt motiviert wenn sie so
auf die dunkle seite der macht gerade
echt ziemlich mies aus leuten die so 30
von den leuten und gefühlte zwei leute
von mir alternativ schlägt sich besser
aber ich muss hier muss er seinen job
seit drei milliarden jahren kein pvp
mehr gespielt
etwa und deshalb könnten deshalb kannst
du london gute chancen aber viel selbst
auch so er nicht gespielt hast du
wirklich dann store beispiel wenn ich
spielen das derzeit nicht nur so sky
bars und nicht so wollen wir es wollen
das spiel immer nur so hätten fast alle
aus so ein bisschen
ich denke mir immer bei dir denke ich
mir schon immer wenig hast du keine
hilfe ich kann noch ganz wacker gegen
polen als ein bisschen doof weil mein
fenster gerade auf ist
diese können das nicht hören haben okay
der macht jetzt seit einem jahr diese
display ist da wird er einfach machen
einfach einschaltet diskutierte zimmer
seid glücklich gelegen dass es so über
der küche wo sich denken gerne aufhält
alter wenn gekocht wird
also wenn du willst dass du nicht
schreiben aber ich will aber nicht mit
meinem volk hier sterben und ich bin ich
so weit laufen
für das gar nicht verstehen dass ich
will nicht so weit laufen argument
verstehe ich vollkommen alter mein gott
sie verfolgen mich das ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen bisschen ärgerlich wenn die
leute hier unten im wasser sind was los
gefühlten zehn leuten verfolgt und als
schutz habe ich ungefähr einen bis 31.12
also ich glaube ich dachte ich werde
vielleicht daran dass nämlich zwei
gemacht ich weiß aber nicht wichtige
macht aber ehrlich gesagt sei froh heute
hat eben die ganze zeit so erbärmlich in
die menge geschossen und ich glaube ich
habe dabei zwei es ist so schrecklich
halt einmal diese das wasser ist echt
extrem stressig mit dem internet mit den
ganzen leuten die abbauen kleinen katzen
mit community fertig dann werde ich
sehen wie viele ist nicht einfach
sechs leute folgen sind sechs leute
gestorben von ihr 30 was die dunkle
seite hier sind die richtige plural von
compass kompasse
ich habe mich das glaube ich schon ein
video gefragt dann haben wir die kumpel
geschrieben
das heißt kompa nahten der wird aber
voll zerlegt hier relativ kritisch da
dein internet glaube ich gerade auch die
doch recht sein
schauen wir paketverlust an felix felix
felix klein verbindungsinformationen
steht ihr der paketverlust 20 prozent
dass es verdammt hoch glaube ich oder
aus kentucky verlust heißt eigentlich
nichts nicht immer was als eingehen und
mit einem guten internet was ich aber
wir werden gleich ins internet laut
bericht von mir die kämpfe nicht die
farben richtig ums partymachen lebt nur
noch aus schwerte zins king will und ich
krieg 29 shop funktion
obwohl ich auch keinen hehl gemacht habe
ja ich würde sagen ich glaube ich werde
das hart gegen dich verpacken
wir haben jetzt drei dass wir uns
schnell die mitte bewegen könnte dann
würde ich sagen
machen wir mal oder ja schon gesagt ein
bisschen angst weil ich total raus
dankeschön ich bin ein bisschen raus aus
pvp weil die spiele aber ich glaube ich
werde ihr schaffen nun vier punkte mit
meinem herzen und mein gedanken werde
ich beim kampf dabei seinen schatten
das glaube ich auch dass so recht wie
ich glaube mein leben nicht um einen
kompass und empfehle ich sagen machen
wir bei den showdown
krankhafter ist 303 entfernen
303 verstehst du hast dir vor was besser
mal zu 330 wegen den youtube klicks
verstehst du weil wir immer einen
geblieben sind aber jetzt jetzt nicht
mehr als 500 300 175 65 57 okay da bist
du schurke max müsste bereit eine klinge
in meinem bauchnabel zu spüren
ja ich eigentlich nicht ein bisschen
angst gerade
meine ganzen special items aus dem
himmel ein klima bin ich okay und
überraschungen aus ich würde mal sagen
ich glaube ich hab das schlechteste team
aller zeiten gehabt kann es kann schon
noch eine grafik gut dass nicht aufnehme
granaten deine schnauze nicht alle
freunde kann man nicht in frieden
vertrag machen das finde ich nicht so
gut wie sie fünf oder so ich hatte null
terodde recht hast du ja ich hab
verloren
da müssen was der tod ja ich weiß
ach so es verstehe ich das okay heute
ich würde sagen kraft haben wie sie will
beim felix gibt es diese woche auch noch
eine revanche sozusagen wo vielleicht
sein team noch besser sein wird
video von max schauen
liiert und macht euch bereit für den
kampf und wir werden unsere rache
kriegen
ok dann würde ich sagen es beim nächsten
mal wieder haut rein macht gut bis dahin